يعني في كان انعدام للرؤيه انه النوع من
الانظمه يؤسس لمخاطر في المستقبل لانه
يعتمد على ايديولوجيا
دينيه على الايديولوجيا وضعيه ممكن الواحد
يعني لا تستطيع ان تناقشها
في تجربه اليسار
ايضا انتهت لمحل كتير شعبوي انتهت بانه
المهم تكون انت ضد امريكا
بس كون ضد امريكا هذا المطلوب هذا منيح
وبنفس الوقت الضمر تراجع البعد التنويري
باليسار مع عدما ديني من ديني هلا مثلا ما
تبقى من اليسار اللبناني وراء حسن نصر
الله
يعني بغض النظر عن اي مناخ ثقافي اي مناخ
فكري ايديولوجي يشيعوا حزب الله بالبلد
فهذا بس كمان الى جانب هل تجربه الضيقه
لليسار
مع مع الثوره الايرانيه كان في اسباب اخرى
من نوع انه
كان في شعور بهالمعسكر العريض اللي بسمي
حاله مناهض للاستعمار او مناهض الامبراليه
او كذا انه
السادات راح على
السادات روحه السادات على
[موسيقى]
78 بعدين توقيع كان
ضربه قاصبه كانت ضربه قاصمه لها معسكر
جبهه الصمود والتصدي بعدين اجت قبلوه
قبلوه لهيدا كانت الحرب اللبنانيه انتهت
واللي انهاها يعني انها ضربوا المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وحلفاء اللبنانيين هو نظام
السوري يعني
صراع داخل البيت واحد يعني بمعنى فكان في
شعور باحباطات متواليه اجت الثوره
الايرانيه
لتعطيه لتعطي هالمعسكر شعور بانه لا القوى
المناهضه للامبرياليه بعد قويه قويه
وقادره
لمن هالشي ادى
لخروج مصر من من الساحه العربيه
ونفس الوقت سوريا متورطه بلبنان
عمل عطا موقع القيادي بالمنطقه لايران
وكانت وقتها وكان وقت الاتحاد السوفيتي
الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه في حينه
الايرانيه لعبه دور مش بس
بتدبير جزئي للبلدين بتدمير اكبر لعلاقات
الاهليه بين السن والشيعه بالمنطقه سريعا
ما تم تطييف الصراع وصار الصراع السني
الشيعي غالب على اي صراع تاني يعني
بعدد من البلدان
وبين وما زال حتى الان يعني